like quran louisiana
louisiana right this is this is god
and they put the picture of the white
god right next to their face the
missionaries came we had the land and
they had the bible but when they left we
had the bible and they had to land
arabic writings verses from the koran
some hadiths written on parchments and
walls and
mounds and so forth
in states in this country in this
country in oklahoma new mexico this is
documented here the blonde hair blue eye
god then over here you go to the nation
and then you got this pakistani fraud
muhammad as a god
[Music]
and i have a special guest now when i
say his name don't jump out of your seat
all right for those that are not
acquainted with the meaning
of your better cartoon
how are you doing ah
now so your first name jihad jihad some
people jumping out of their sheets
they should be jumping for joy and just
simply put jihad means struggle
we all want to do good things whether
we're christian jewish otherwise and
that jihad begins with yourself that you
had if i want to do good charity i want
to improve my neighborhood
it is a struggle and we want to please
if you have faith you want to please
your your lord and that your head starts
with yourself and so it's different
forms of that you have it's what your
intentions your tongue and your hand
and if they're
as men and responsible
citizens
if something comes to the fore
you might have to raise up to your hand
and a lot of people
confuse the words you had with the word
harp
harp is the disruptive destructive
form what you had is always good and
just been
misappropriated so those of us that know
better has to do a better job rather
than cowering and letting the mis
representation of jihad permeate so no
jihad
everybody should you had you get up in
the mornings that you had i thought you
had to make a good uh grade on my paper
you were doing some jihad even before
you were muslim as a chicago cop you
know against uh criminals no you're a
chicago cop for how long
not too long it was just
a fleeting experience with the uh
chicago police department i also worked
for the uh
city of chicago in the research
department uh
uh doing some statisticals i was a
statistician yeah i don't know how let's
get the number and running uh
jobs and now you now we're in miami huh
you're develop what you do developing
here for a developer
addressing the uh social economic
inequities uh working hard to put for
sustainable housing projects
you have to do housing
if i was
if you go into medical professions you
got surgeons you got practitioners and
therapists and in economic development i
think housing is important because
housing buttresses
educational attainment
job sustainability
and attempts now social dysfunctions in
the family so that has always been
elusive to uh
african americans and others that have
been shut out do you have any life
stories let's go back to your name
before you push forward tell me like
this seems like a really good
opportunity to share like you know when
have you ever had someone you meet
someone say a christian or somebody
who's not yet muslim and you introduce
yourself and everything smiles right and
then you say what's your name jihad have
you ever had someone get taken back and
then it's a great opening to go ahead
and like you just did well
not so much surprisingly with all the
hullabaloo about jihad i i can't
hold on to a lot of
bad experiences people probably mutter
behind my back but it's out of ignorance
and recently somebody say oh jihad holy
war they think they know something but
if you say that you're going to get
education so i'm going to tell you about
jihad and i'm going to tell you about
you didn't want to know because i want
to hold on all these distortions about
muslims in islam and now you came and
showed me that i was wrong i wish i had
kept my mouth shut so i shouldn't have
said anything about jihad
because now you know better yes yes so
always a good teaching opportunity
that's really important so let's couple
moments teachable moments let's go back
to your early beginnings now you grew up
in a christian baptist household yes yes
yeah uh tell us about that how was your
early years
it's mostly about the order it was
really more akin to the more
moral order that permeated this country
in the society we were moral in general
we wasn't
book wild and loosely goosey and extreme
in those days so whether you're a
baptist or whatever denomination
what was in the household
is respect for elders
seeking education being a good neighbor
be a good citizen and the theological
part of it was a smorgasbord of
different things so some people were in
the holiness church or the sanctified
church or the methodist or the
presbyterian or the african methods
methodist episcopalian
but in general when you walked out of
your house you didn't always know what
brand of christianity folks were but
what we had was
that
a
proper upbringing
about that even though it was christian
uh
in the early days i used to see this
picture my father was a commercial
artist
and uh
i used to see this picture of a
white image of jesus and he was praying
and then later i found out where did you
see this image now it was somewhere one
of the churches
and then was it in the in the uh
in a church
he was up against a rock and he was
praying like this and he was the white
jesus white jesus yeah yeah now was this
in an african-american church or yeah
all the african-american church had
white jesus yeah every one of them i
heard some of them you go that he had uh
african-american jesus i've seen that
that didn't come until after the nation
islam
is has to be attributed from vanquishing
the image of white jesus in a a good
number of churches so they were
responsible for that they were
responsible for that i bear witness they
were okay so let's go back so you see
the white jesus now blue eyes
of course of course
you know it's just like uh somebody used
to tell me a story they so they would go
to different countries or the
undeveloped native country and they come
uh with a picture this is
this is this is god
and they put the picture of the white
guard right next to their face so the
folks say well that must be god's cousin
a son or grandson so i better do what he
says
it was it was a tool of colonialism
a tool of colonialism right i want to i
want your minerals and i want your labor
and i want to
i want to put you to work that benefits
me and so one of the ways you can do
that is like another little amusing
thing that we always say
is that when
when the uh
the missionaries came we had the land
and they had the bible but when they
left we had the bible and they had to
land
so
that was foundation foundational to the
subjugation in the world today
uh
that's not the problem of all christians
because there are christians that are
sincere they just don't have all the
information that some of the rest of us
have when did you find out in history we
were talking earlier and you
you talk about how 600 years how the
muslims
before columbus were here and then they
came alongside with columbus right and
having such a big stake in america so
when people start you know some of these
islamophobes and very uneducated people
who don't know history right but then
they come out and say go back to afro go
back home yeah right well
you know you have the nerve and the gall
uh word not for those muslims uh
uh
it's places
that you know like quran louisiana
louisiana right
mecca california
muslims was there they left their
imprint they you have writings or if you
were talking about egyptology or greek
holographics but you would see
uh
arabic writings verses from the koran
uh some hadiths written on parchments
and walls and
on mounds and so forth
in states in this country in this
country in oklahoma new mexico this is
documented this is this document it's
not fiction people can look this up yeah
it's part of the
three part tragedy that's been beset
upon this country
genocide
um
a form a slavery
and omission
the omission continues the mission
omitting that history we just
we're one day out of uh black history
month there shouldn't be such thing as
black history month the only reason
that's a black history month is because
they leave out the history
and if we are successful we won't need
to have a black history month history is
history no matter who does it and so i
think what you were asking me
about muslims i you know there's a great
explosion of immigration from people
from muslim countries
in the last 20 years
and they come
sometimes bending backwards and
sometimes i think overdoing it i think
those muslims that come here should be
very presumptive you don't have to keep
apologizing we i used to criticize us in
the black struggle stop apologizing for
something that you're not responsible
for stop apologizing for something that
you don't do take that time and acquaint
people about islam and be matter of fact
about it in fact
you have a stake in this country because
muslims were here not because they were
black because they were muslims so
muslims have been here foundationally
america is an industrial technological
military giant proportion to the
contributions that those africans
brought to this country
they happen to be muslims and i say to
muslims because
the muslims that they did the africans
they brought over this country were two
types they were either muslim or they
were animists or ancestor worship
the muslims were literate they were
educated they could read so when they
got here they became the quartermaster
of the supplies and sometimes they was
paired with a very ignorant
straw boss
white guy who could beat and whip but he
couldn't count he couldn't read so he
would have his first assistant would be
this african and the african would be a
muslim because the muslims can count on
reid they had agriculture they knew crop
rotations they knew the stars they knew
everything there was part of remorse
but even more
over archaeologically and
anthropologically
there's a
personality in a muslim history called
masamusa
and it says he
went from the west to margaret to the
east he had so much gold the price of
gold fell had more gold and his
predecessor
set sail
to the west with 200 ships and were
never seen again and they came to the
americas and so some accounts suggest
that
that
muslims
africans were here 800 years before
columbus
and that's why queen isabella and
ferdinand got a notion of got a sense
something was happening and then they
and conscripted
some navigators and people who can chart
the stars and they were muslims because
they built the
astrologe
and the telescopes and knew the stars
and had the math so
they they brought them here so no muslim
has to apologize for it they have
representation muslims here and because
this deen tells us not to set ourselves
in what racial dis uh
distinction the last sermon that prophet
muhammed
god be pleased with him said there
the the the the black is not better than
the white or the air
the non-air better than non-air and back
and forth so we were representatives of
islam
more than we were representative of just
men africans and that's how we brought
here and we brought those things that
are foundational that made
america the
economic industrial
military technological giant that it is
today
that's deep wow
now if you go from
this part of your life you had a short
journey also to the nation correct right
yeah can we talk about that before we
get into what led you to actually coming
to true orthodox is islam
um
what i later found upon is that it was
the struggle we read the books one was
getting our identity when i was in
grammar school uh if you would call
black
and you see how people
of caucasian race they get they blush
and get red if you call a black person
uh black
they were
they were bullish
out of shame
ashamed that's how we felt
uh about ourselves worthlessness and
through the agency of the nation they
gave a pill
black is beautiful black is good
oh in fact you're more than a color
you're not just a black man
you're a african man they're responsible
for we referring to ourselves as african
americans that is attributed to the
leadership of wd muhammad in terms of
that we got out at negro color even
black black was too even too limiting
for us so the nation islam and then when
i and just go a little bit forward now
come back real quick is that
uh
god allah
in the quran says i bring the living
from the dead and the dead for the
living we were dead to the knowledge of
our true selves we were dead
and to the knowledge of uh
our history and our contributions and
with the agency of the the nation islam
we want
got a sense of pride
in ourselves and understanding that it
was good and we had good spokesmen
unwittingly like muhammad ali
and malik
el hajj el shabazz
commonly referred to as malcolm x who
were bold
who were bold there were some muslims
here they might have been from
turkey and other albania or other places
it was pockets of those muslims here but
they practice their islam in secret
but the nation
practiced islam in your face
and we learned that
god was allah and that quran was the
book revealed by
allah to his last your mohammed mugabe
policeman that was the jumping off point
so if you look at the nation uh muslims
who are strictly adhering to their faith
as they should would see that it wasn't
perfect but then i go back to
i bring the living from the dead and the
dead from the living so you can use some
waste matter and grow some good crops so
this is way way more better than that so
this was where we got to the point we
are when if you're a muslim and you came
here in the last 30 years then thank
allah for the nation islam marcus garvey
elijah muhammad and warrior muhammad and
others and this and it's more others
than i can speak to now
i should quickly give some attribution
to
dr
uh
hakeem quick
he's um
quick update
he could give you he can do this much
better than me but that is a great
resource in terms of the uh history
history of
africans in america now what you
talk about is you'd flip over
the one of the biggest newspapers right
in chicago or in america
that was the nation news what was it
called oh well it started out as the
well early early days was a final call
then it became
and then became muhammad speak yeah then
mama speaks became what is known as the
uh the bilalian news and then the muslim
journal that was the evolutionary part
then
uh far khan
changed his name to abdul haleem farah
khan went to mecca and all that stuff
and was with
warranty muhammad but then he broke away
and revived the final call yeah so you
have in christianity where there was the
worship of jesus and then turning him
into a god son of god into a triune god
then you come over to the nation and you
flip that newspaper and there
in the articles of faith now you have
one of the beliefs is believing for our
muhammad is god so where these things
you know we have the fitra the innate
disposition you know what i mean
and now
attributing divinity to the creation is
something that usually is just kind of
your fitrah innate disposition it kind
of rejects so were you feeling how was
your feeling towards going from here the
blonde hair blue eye
god then over here you go to the nation
and then you got this uh pakistani fraud
muhammad as a god
well
it was kind of dicey but in a
practical sense they were in since
saying he was god personally
i just never grasped onto that they said
he appeared in the person of god not
making any excuses for him
but
it's just a little tiny nuance they
didn't say farad is god
but
that was problematic that was
problematic and all of us young folks we
were in the black movement in the civil
rights structure we were just learning
to love and appreciate our identity and
ourselves and learning our history
so you had all this
and then you had this theology and
flawed as it was
it was
somewhat acceptable because they also
insisted that
god was
somehow
uh
more resembling the black experience in
a black persona
but
what we did we just got into a staging
area
to get the true islam
we would not have gotten it
had we not went through that movement
and
coming through that and looking back on
it
we're praying very hard that allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala guides
brother farah i mean he could be uh one
of the most powerful men on earth
if he embraced the full sunnah
and that we pray that he gets this and
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala forgives him
for his sins shortcomings and his his
misguidance
uh on this area
uh because that is
uh what is on the black back of that
newspaper is antithetical to islam
that's the opposite to islam it isn't
that
i mean you can't criticize christianity
and embrace that
because that would be the same
but
usually people outside of islam they
focus on these exceptions now like in
christianity you have
countless dominations
denominations and stuff
and the overwhelming majority of muslims
are on what we refer to as the sunnah
rasulallah
and in the practical everyday life the
most impactful part of islam is the
people that follow the right
but generally we get more inquiry
from outside islam about those things
they do the same thing about shia versus
sunni
you know and we spend more time than
it's worth talking about those
differences and so i always like to
bring the conversation back to islam
because
the proof is in the pudding so if you
present islam as it is if somebody would
sit down and listen
to what allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala has
god be highly praised and glorified
what he said
compared to what somebody else said that
they don't have any basis we wouldn't
have to have as much conversation about
it so
personally i
try to not take up the oxygen in the air
and the time to put too much discussion
on it
as i could be seeing something that is
true and relevant to true islam
inception because he's not that
impactful except
that
very organized
and otherwise progressive
but i will say one thing it's just like
people will say well i'm a good person i
do charity i do work i'm clean
i'm nice i'm not racist
but allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala says i
only created mankind and the gender
worshipped me so if you're all that nice
and you're good and you're clean and you
don't love and respect allah
god then it doesn't it's not gonna
benefit you that much you but god's
going to give you some measure but that
might not get you where you want to go
yeah it might not keep you out of the
hellfire so those who
focus on islam
is exception and whatever the mistakes
they are
maybe they're in the staging ground and
maybe they'll get out of it but the
overwhelming
bulk majority of muslims that's worth
talking about is the ones that are
practicing right and those who call
themselves muslims the majority of them
are practicing right muslims so
we keep continuing to be a good example
and not spend so much time because i if
we turn around to criticize them that's
what
the powers that don't mean either side
any good because farrakhan is doing a
lot of great things he's just not
some of us think that he can do a well
of a better job of representing islam if
he's going to say islam yeah it's like
it reminded me it's like somebody who's
uh has all these qualities but they're
not showing up to class
they're not showing up to work you know
what i mean at the end of the day
you know you're not going to pass that
test if you don't go ahead and
show up to class and do what your
professor told you to do but in this
greater context what our creator wants
us to do now you end up doing that you
end up in the last few minutes that we
have talk about the the difference now
when you got exposed to the pure
monotheism the tokid
of islam submission to the creator not
the creation
uh well alhamdulillah i'll praise to god
that
he says i now have created you except
for the worship of me i remember taking
uh
philosophy courses at depaul university
i don't know why a good catholic
university was not spend more time on
their theology and without this john
paul thought things what's the purpose
of life what's the meaning of man
well islam answered that question
you the purpose of your life is to
worship me you come from me and you're
gonna come back to me
and i've given you
your your human manual and i'm giving
you a person
who's that manual walking that was this
prophet who provided for us
a perfect example
of human conduct as a husband a father a
businessman
and it's a general
so that we can conduct ourselves how we
can do
cosmopolitan things
interacting with people to intimate
things like going to the toilet eating
with our right hand and cleansing
ourselves when we come in from the
privity with our left hand
those of the important things about this
line so that we can conduct our lives
and it is short
and in short and we and this is a portal
it's a portal and we're taught that we
are created on two natures and we are
going to mirror and pinch ourselves and
say yes that's me
but actually
we ride this physical
body like you would drive a car
the car is going to wear out
but the superior part of yourself is
going to keep going on that's going to
take the responsibility starting in the
grave
and we will get punished in the grave if
we didn't
follow that manual
and we don't follow that manual then
we uh we're lost
but the best of those who show mercy is
god all money and he's going to give you
your justice even if it's just the
weight of a mustard seed so
you have to beware
and when you get in this stage of life
like this clock is ticking down now you
get more consciousness and what we call
muslims call taqwa consciousness about
it it's not the distraction and that
book tells us it's not about the big
boogie the big party the fancy clothes
and all that stuff is about that
eventual meeting
by which there is no doubt
no doubt that you're going to meet
your lord
you're going to come out of here and go
through this porto
called death in the grave and you're
going to be brought out of it so we live
this life so that we can get that
uh permanent eternal life
pleasing him who gave us whatever we got
the next breath that i breathe is given
to me
and whatever we got comes from
almighty god i want to thank you thank
you for spending some time with us and
sharing uh some of your story i really
appreciate inshallah i could be of
inspiration motivation for
uh many more out there my life and my
depth is for allah i'm in the lord of
the worlds thank you thank you thank you
very much
and thank you guys for tuning in if
you'd like a free copy of the quran to
learn more
visit
thedeanshow.com and if you still have
any questions go ahead and call us at
1-800-662-islam 4752 we'll see you next
time here on the dean show subscribe if
you haven't already to get all of our
up-and-coming shows so you don't miss
out and we'll see you next time
inshallah until then peace be with you
assalamu alaikum and if you like this
episode of the dean show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum